Eraclio est un llamero.
Il dirige des caravanes de lamas.
Pour gagner sa vie, Eraclio
traverse le plus grand désert de sel du monde
deux fois par an.
Il descend
de l'Altiplano aux basses terres,
où il échange des blocs de sel contre des marchandises.
Eraclio possède plus de 100 lamas.
Quelques jours avant de partir
lors de son voyage printanier,
il abat ses meilleurs animaux
des pâturages supérieurs
et compose sa caravane.
Une vingtaine, pas plus.
Hilaron est le plus ancien llamero
dans le village.
Il a dû renoncer aux longues traversées
il y a deux ans
parce qu'il ne pouvait plus marcher.
Hilaron souffre d'une blessure profonde.
Son fils, Roberto,
a vécu dans son propre monde
depuis sa naissance,
le monde du silence.
Les villageois disent
c'est un enfant des dieux.
Si Eraclio avait un fils,
il lui montrerait
comment choisir les mâles les plus vigoureux
et comment serrer les sangles
sans blesser les animaux.
Il l'emmènerait sur les sentiers
dans les riches vallées,
et apprends-lui à regarder le ciel
et parle aux étoiles.
Roberto ne se rend pas compte de tout cela.
Roberto n'a qu'un seul ami,
son lama blanc.
Il n'y a pas de routes dans ces montagnes.
Pas de facteur.
Quand Eraclio part,
tout le monde dans le village lui demande
offrir un cadeau à un parent éloigné.
Le llamero connaît tous les secrets.
Il est le confident,
le messager discret.
Il participe à toutes les histoires d'amour
sur l'Altiplano.
Pour cette femme,
une lettre à son mari, Elias,
qui travaille dans les mines de sel.
Eraclio choisit bien ses mots,
ceux qui apportent du réconfort.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Pour cette femme, un cadeau à sa fille
sur le point d'accoucher.
Eraclio le portera
pour les villages sur sa route.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Eraclio se rend dans les maisons les plus reculées
pour rassembler les colis de ses voisins.
La dame tisserande
veut qu'il rapporte des fruits
en échange des châles qu'elle a confectionnés.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Le vieux Hilarón
sait qu'Eraclio part demain.
Il aimerait son Roberto
faire aussi le grand voyage.
Sur ces plateaux arides,
un champ de bataille pour les volcans,
tu ne pars jamais,
que ce soit pour une heure, un jour ou un mois
sans faire d'offrande au préalable
à Pachamama,
la mère de la Terre et des montagnes.
Le vieux llamero a pris sa décision.
Il va demander à Eraclio
pour emmener son fils.
Cependant, Roberto doit être d'accord
laisser derrière lui son Lama blanc.
Tard dans la nuit, les mots s'envolent
du village reculé, mots quechua,
la langue inca.
Mots simples.
Celles d'un père inquiet.
Des mots qui disent,
"Demain, tu partiras avec Eraclio.
Roberto, entends-tu mes paroles?»
Les caravanes ont toujours un lama en tête.
C'est toujours le plus courageux et le plus fort.
Aussi, celui
qui est le plus proche du llamero.
Pendant le voyage, les autres animaux le suivent
et il obéit aux ordres du llamero.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Eraclio a des doutes.
Le voyage sera difficile
et le jeune garçon est si différent.
Cependant, entre les appels,
certaines choses ne peuvent être refusées.
Eraclio et le petit Roberto
je reviendrai dans trois mois.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Les lamas subissent des conditions sévères
sur les caravanes.
Ils marchent pendant des heures
sans boire ni manger.
Eraclio considère le lama,
à la fois une mule et un mouton roulés en un seul.
Pachamama a également béni l'animal
avec des coussins sur ses sabots
cela le rend aussi silencieux que le puma.
Les jours passent.
Roberto marche.
Il ne se plaint pas.
Il ne sourit pas.
Eraclio se sent seul avec ses lamas.
Eux, il les connaît.
Cependant, cette petite créature fragile,
tout enveloppé dans sa laine et son poncho,
est au-delà de lui.
Chaque fois que le troupeau s'arrête,
Roberto se blottit parmi eux.
C'est le seul endroit
il semble prendre vie.
Les hommes et les lamas ont vécu ensemble
Pour des milliers d'années.
Il y a cinq siècles,
les Incas envoyèrent des centaines de caravanes
à travers les Andes
pour construire et approvisionner leur immense empire.
Aujourd'hui, Eraclio parcourt les mêmes itinéraires.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Une femme est sur le point d'accoucher.
La poupée représente un bébé mâle.
Il exaucera les vœux
de la future maman.
Roberto n'avait pas de mère.
Il n'a jamais côtoyé une femme enceinte.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Avant de traverser le désert de sel,
une visite à Carlos s'impose.
Carlos fabrique des chaussures et des lunettes
pour les lamas.
Il dit que le Salar rend fou,
que le soleil se mélange au sel
brûler les yeux et les pieds de tout vivant
être en train de le traverser.
Eraclio a déjà tout entendu,
mais il fait toujours semblant d'écouter
comme si c'était la première fois.
Le Salar n’est pas une affaire de rire.
Les Incas ont construit des villes entières
pour étudier les étoiles.
Comme tout son peuple, Eraclio
a hérité d’une partie de son savoir.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Comme eux, il lit son chemin dans les étoiles.
Il lit le sort du llamero.
Là-haut, tous les aspects de la vie sont écrits.
Il voit le lama et son ennemi, le puma,
mais aussi les rotondes,
la navette du tisserand,
et les tombeaux de ses ancêtres.
Loin de là, vieux Hilaron
regrette de ne pas être avec son fils
pour lui parler du grand désert blanc
des nuits
quand le puma rôde autour du troupeau,
et de Pachamama,
qui ne l'a jamais abandonné.
Le Salar de Uyuni est le seul possible
route vers le sud pour les caravanes.
Trois cents kilomètres de Désert Blanc,
ponctué ici et là
par de petites îles de lave brune.
Eraclio avait l'âge de Roberto
quand il a traversé pour la première fois.
Eraclio achète ses blocs de sel
à la seule mine du Salar.
C'est ici qu'Elias travaille.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Les Salineros sortent de la croûte de cristal
15 heures par jour.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Cela fait six mois
depuis qu'Elias a reçu des nouvelles de sa femme.
Eraclio rapportera un peu d'argent
au village.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Le sel est chargé
sur le bord volcanique du Salar.
Deux blocs par lama, 24 kilos par animal.
Pas plus.
Eraclio prévient Roberto
sur tous les risques de la grande traversée
et comment les éviter.
Ils seront seuls.
Ils devront être forts.
Marcher marcher,
et ne pense à rien d'autre.
Un puma affamé
erre parfois dans le désert de sel.
La nuit, il peut tuer un lama
avec une seule barre oblique,
lui trancher la gorge et l'entraîner jusqu'au bord.
Eraclio, comme tous les llamero,
sait qu'il ne fera rien
pour arrêter le gros chat.
Le puma est sacré.
Le soleil brûle les yeux.
Le sel ronge la chair.
Ce n’est pas un endroit pour les êtres vivants.
La laine de lama absorbe le soleil et le sel
radiations.
Les Llameros l'utilisent
pour protéger les yeux de leurs animaux.
Un homme ne traverse jamais le Salar
sans bonnet en laine de lama.
Dans le Salar, tu marches la nuit
et cachez-vous pour dormir pendant la journée.
Eraclio a lu quelque chose dans les étoiles.
La légende raconte qu'un lama affamé
essaie de dévorer le soleil
afin de répandre les ténèbres
et créer le chaos sur Terre.
Pachamama seule
peut rétablir le bon ordre des choses.
Quelques feuilles de coca et un peu d'alcool
va apaiser sa colère.
Eraclio prie jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit.
Roberto s'est endormi.
Les lamas ont fui.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Dans le Salar, et sans le llamero,
les lamas ont toujours la tête
à l'île la plus proche
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils trouveront de la nourriture.
Pourtant, dans ce désert,
l'île la plus proche,
même si cela semble proche,
peut être dans plusieurs jours.
Pour la première fois, Roberto ouvre la voie.
Il veut récupérer ses lamas.
La blessure n'est pas grave.
Le puma s'est enfui avec un animal,
mais le reste du troupeau est en sécurité.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Dans une semaine,
ils atteindront leur destination.
Le soleil noir n'a pas été oublié
dans la Vallée des Fleurs.
Roberto est accueilli comme un héros.
Les gens attendaient
pour les llameros et leur sel
depuis des mois maintenant.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Sur le chemin du retour, Eraclio
a laissé le petit Roberto conduire la caravane.
Il leur a fallu un mois pour rentrer chez eux.
En chemin, ils rendirent une autre visite
à la jeune maman.
Elle a eu un petit garçon.
Elle l'appelait Roberto.
Avec l'argent, la femme d'Elias,
le mineur de sel, envisage d'acheter quelques lamas.
Elle a besoin de laine.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Le tisserand avait rêvé
à propos de ces pommes depuis des mois.
Tout le village
je les apprécierai avec elle.
Le voyage est terminé.
Le petit Roberto est devenu un llamero.
[Audio parlé quechua]
Désormais, Roberto peut diriger une caravane.
L'espoir est revenu dans le cœur du vieux Hilaron.
Le village a trouvé un nouveau llamero.
Roberto, bien sûr,
ne parle toujours pas avec les humains,
mais tout le monde comptera sur lui.
Il est toujours l'enfant des dieux.